The operator I've used here, simply a single plus prepended to
the attendance field, is what's called the unary operator.
It's a little JavaScript trick to convert a string into an integer.
I'm sure if you've used JavaScript or other programming languages,
you've used the unary plus operator's sister, the unary negation operator.
In this case, a single minus sign.
In this case, with a single minus sign, we're simply negating the value.
Which usually makes pretty intuitive sense.
The unary plus, on the other hand, looks a little bit more strange.
Again, whatever you put it in front of, it tries to convert into a numeric form.
In this case, since attendance is an integer, it will convert it
into an integer and then update the value of the attendance column.
If we try to use the unary plus or
the unary negative on something like a string that doesn't have
a natural numeric representation, we'll simply get not a number back.
And if you're curious, I encourage you to experiment in a web browser console or
other JavaScript environment